[Music]
we're going to Gary's baby's birthday
party URIs a my hair girl my makeup girl
who did everything for the wedding close
friend of ours
she also cuts the boys hair going to her
baby's birthday party and then later
we're gonna go see mama and yay yay and
Isaac they're heading to Japan and on
their way to Japan they're gonna have a
very long way over in LA so he got to
see Casey's parents before they allude
to Japan how cute everything's on
medical theme so we're always right
everything matches your he's so good at
every party she's always making sure
there's a theme
[Music]
we've got the picture like the chip not
really give it I'll see it I like who
does the head this chips are a dime a
dozen macaroons out take some savoring I
couldn't take the whole thing it's too
much macaroni one bite
[Applause]
let's go we're leaving what happens is
there's a fire all of a sudden you got a
runaway we're leaving you behind that
beautiful party goofy mom already super
mom party goofy
[Music]
every time we come to the airport and
we're not leaving I kind of get a little
sad because I like coming to the airport
when I know I'm gonna be going on a trip
do you guys ever get FOMO whenever you
come to the airport and you know you're
not flying out yourselves fellow means
fear of missing out in case you didn't
know Isaac we're still cooler than Isaac
right there maybe a teenager a couple
years sure did you know it if what full
moment baby oh yes if do you ever feel
like like oh man I wouldn't go on a trip
to every time I come to the airport to
pick someone up or drop someone off okay
yeah I'm feeling that right now I'm like
oh we're at the airport
but we're not the ones leaving I'm
actually so excited for your parents cuz
it's gonna be the first time that they
get to explore Japan your parents have
never been in Japan yeah my dad's always
been really anti Japan is he holds his
Chinese nationality pride close to heart
so he's never really cared too much
about being in Japan but ever since I
went to Japan he's been kind of like
Japan really fun luxurious yeah cuz uh
mama
sister taurima she goes to Japan often
and I know that she's always telling my
my like oh you guys should go to Japan
it's so beautiful it's such a beautiful
country but yeah like keeps you sane
baba is always like no I don't want to
go to Japan but then now that we've gone
he's kind of experience full moon yeah
he he actually experienced FOMO so I'm
really excited slash jealous that
they're going
she looks so big now you don't look cute
anymore I think it's not cute
we try to run more cute now here they oh
I'm not cute I'll show you what cute is
[Music]
[Applause]
why is he what
we never get to pick you guys up it's
always you guys picking us up in Douglas
right yeah all right Hollis a home look
look how pretty is it
I tie my shoes whoa so do you have a
kick of shoes I did this house you don't
have to you know we don't have carpet do
you like our carpet no hey take it off
my shoes I'm the worst kind of Asian
because I don't might take it off my
shoes I don't know I just feel I feel
more ready to go just in case things
happen with my shoes on
[Music]
what do you think in the piano it's not
freaky yeah yeah sounds good right
please fart oh yeah then be alright your
mouth I hadn't seen my fart inside the
car is not hard thank you I've been
there before I know how do you say
Chinese New Year in Chinese go near my
toy suddenly also I was totally worth
taking you guys up hahahaha so China
will say cycle jump I miss you
[Music]
in a fast
bonus cool before you guys leave some
points
hurry ever give me a grant grandchild
it's precious on you lonely sound
quality actually it means give me a baby
every year
[Music]
why don't you pull there's a Mexican
flag why don't I get something white for
a white wall I like this though it looks
cool yeah we're improving it I don't
want to move to the chaplains who I
don't like tell her there I like Chaplin
there it's like the one the one manly
thing here
I don't know Chaplin actually represents
manliness but since I'm a man I've been
saying I was going to do videos here and
I just haven't gone around to do it but
it's here the set is here just got a set
up the camera and figure out a video the
one makeup video I made is like the only
makeup style I know how to create like I
don't know you were telling me earlier
today you you did something different
with your eyes Oh barely I would just
put eyeshadow or eyeliner on the edge
it's like one different but you know I
can tell is it
[Music]
all right so dead now that I've moved
down to LA and have found some stability
doing what I do here married and then
now your other son five years learning
than me my brother Carrie he's also
moved out has a girlfriend and is living
and stable what do you think it's a
relief that yes they move on to their
next stage of in life and I now move on
to my next stage in life as well are you
happy to be in the next stage in life or
do you miss you know parts of the
previous yeah I do I do miss it of
course I do miss all these you know
lounges in the house and now he's quiet
you know and but it's still it's just a
just life
you know yeah everything moves on you
know with the without you know and
that's the way of leg is I think the
house of we would have right now is too
big for two people
we already dance I see are you gonna
downsize again dollar it's too much work
too much work to move around that's true
you know so when you were 30 years old
did you ever wonder what life would be
like when you were sixty and did you
ever like visualize what like I'm trying
to keep my Asia secret right now I never
thought of that
actually never visualized your your life
30 years in ahead no yeah yeah maybe
show you guys a picture I just scan onto
my thing when you say 30 years ago of me
this is 30 years ago of me wow you have
is in your phone yes that's you so
that's you 30 years old I'm on the same
age as you are in that picture yes and
then mama you're 28
yes damn you got to see this that's my
parents when they were our age
that's KC age and this your age this
she's not there yet to be announced he's
in that picture to me yeah I sent it to
you does that feel like it wasn't that
long ago when you look back on all that
yes and no some stuff like oh yeah it's
a long time ago something like yeah I
was a banker as you can see yeah yeah so
it was you know suit and ties and things
like that I just came home from work and
we took that picture I don't know
selfies didn't exist back then you never
think of who's the one behind the camera
well now in our generation we never have
to think about it well it's the default
thing is to do the selfie yeah look at
this one this one when I was 20 year old
oh yeah I remember this my knife you you
know why it's all creased stuff like
destroyed all right so I always liked
eating Chinese through of my parents
because they always like to go for the
good stuff that I don't know how to
order
what are you eating I like it it's like
a burgess bat into my soup
that's a boogie like it all right so
we're about to eat some sea cucumber
my own son is bullying me on
I thought I know why they gross me out
so much I'm like this is like a huge
booger that's gross
like oh you remember that thought
because when you buy embrace that go to
venture is lemon adventures real talk
though Chinese people love the booger
mucus texture when they're eating
it's like real Chinese food they embrace
that slimy texture for some reason I
love it myself too though you're a real
Chinese man Yeah right
oh man all right
[Music]
the texture is so weird
it doesn't taste that was bomb like
tasteless or flavorless I mean are you
ready so you're training for Hong Kong
you're gonna be going to Hong Kong soon
sometime in your future you got it
his mom's a high five
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
that's my dad's idea of a pep talk right
now we were talking about how we're
wondering how Isaac's gonna change once
he hits puberty and like you know
everyone changes I was like yeah you
know it's a good thing you don't live
with me because I know come foo yeah
I'll come for you down at this you know
Chinese guy you know what they do they
don't care about your feeling hey don't
we don't care about your feeling is the
only American even of bumble this you
say have some kind of reward
[Music]